me laughs I'm the love peace be with you
thank you for tuning in to the Dean show
very interesting topic today Aaron
Hernandez if you guys haven't heard
about it we're gonna be talking about
his life a little bit here NFL football
player was about to make 40 million
dollar dollars now he's sitting in the
jail so how'd it end up there how you
know how do you end up there my next
guess we're gonna be talking about drugs
we're gonna be talking about music we're
gonna be talking about all the things
out there that interests a lot of people
so don't go anywhere we're right back
with this very hot topic here Indonesia
this is the back here Nadine show hot on
how you doing brother
Salaam honorable peace we would think
well alaikum Salaam how's it going I'm
gonna get ourself hamdullah hamdulillah
we're trying to really help people
understand the purpose of life and we
see what happens to people when they
don't live the purpose of life right you
know end up in some real bad
predicaments we have Aaron Hernandez who
was on his way to be making a whole lot
of money forty million dollars could you
imagine that went from being in the hood
to the NFL and now he's in a jail cell
well so we want to try to analyze his
life a little bit and see like what
would lead someone you know he's still
not convict guilty but you know a lot of
times association you know with the
wrong crowd can have you and Victor
convicted right so we want to you know a
lot of people are idolizing the the
people such as himself and they look up
to him they think this whole you know
thug lifestyle is something that's cool
and if we can help change someone's life
for the better a lot of the you know you
see a gentleman like that he wasn't a
kid right you know but he sees he's
still emulating you know a lot of the
the rappers and lot of the word people
get these crazy ideas and they end up
going and maybe watching Goodfellas Tony
Montana then they try to you know take
it to the streets and you see what
happens yeah so what are you thoughts on
this well you know a lot of times we
believe that the fame and money buys us
happiness it buys us peace in our hearts
it buys us you know whatever it is we're
looking for and there's absolutely a
fabric its absolute fabric
when we if we were to analyze the
reports for example that the guy you
know Hernandez had what people said
about him prior to the events you know
prior to the few days before you can see
that even with all his money this guy
was really really looking for happiness
right he was begging for happiness you
know he had women money cars everything
that he could materially want but that
happiness that peace of heart he still
was searching for it and proof and
evidence of that is that he needed it
every day now he's sitting in the jail
cell without it and he's probably
talking about what he had you know just
a few weeks ago right so and he misses
that now no one is safe and secure from
going to jail right the best of the best
of us have gone to jail right prophets
have been imprisoned they've the people
have been accused of doing things but
the question is which one of the two had
the peace of heart had the completion of
life so we're gonna take for example him
and we're going to look at the story of
a very common person among the people of
the book
Joseph Yusuf auda Saddam was one of the
prophets of God he was one of the
prophets of God yeah
who was also accused he was also
convicted and he was he also spent a lot
of time in jail yeah he was betrayed by
his family right so before we start I
want to start with a statement that he
said towards the end and he says inhuman
yes Chuck near a hospital for inna llaha
la blue a general most saying indeed for
those who fear God meaning stay away
from the that which God has forbidden
and remain steadfast and patient God
never forsakes the rewarding of those
who strive towards his perfection okay
so now we're going to look at two
similar situations situation number 1
2013 Hernandez
messes up and he ends up going to jail
right when I were gonna go back about
5,000 years the story of Yusuf Ali
Saddam may the peace and blessing be
upon him is falsely accused or we're
gonna go back even further he's betrayed
by his brothers and he's thrown into a
well and sold out to slavery falsely
accused
eventually goes to jail right while he's
in jail what does he have is he talking
about how many women he had had right
how much money he had
how much cars he had how much money he
used to spend no he's talking about what
he has because he's still content with
what he has which was so he'd oneness of
Allah oneness of God
pure monotheism right devotion to God so
now we're gonna move back up you know
another 5,000 years I want to come back
to today's situation here he is
convicted a grown man for the first time
ever going to jail many times will cry
cry you could imagine the different
things that are going through his head
40 million dollars I just blew it he's
been in jail before I'm sure he's been
he's been in jail he's been had run-ins
with the police before yes but nothing
this big nothing is big yeah so now he
has
all that money you know this is this was
going through his head all of that money
that's what he used to worship is that
money yep all of those women that's what
he used to worship true here right all
of those cars that's what he used to
worship mm-hmm so guess what all of that
stuff that you just used to worship has
left you and why are you I'm trying to
figure out if you're you have all this
money and many people think okay I get
the money I get the women I'm gonna be
happy a great career I mean people just
fantasize you know about being in the
NFL and it's a major league baseball
whatever the case but he's on angel dust
you've heard of this angel dust
what his angel does it's a horrible drug
I believe it's it's a form of acid yeah
from what I understand which causes
hallucinations and a whole bunch of
other what the hell are you doing an
angel dust can I say that no what are
you doing on angel dust you got all this
money you know what you're smoking
rolling up blunts you know the guy that
actually that he killed that would they
say he killed the guy Lloyd he was known
for wrong as blunts up for him mmm right
so why you smoking angel dust blunts and
alcohol and you had strip clubs and you
know and now you're come into you know
allegedly committing a murder he was
already killing themselves yeah you're
already killing the holiday game so are
you living the purpose of life the way
it's intended for you to live by the
crater if you're doing all these things
mmm not at all not at all not at all and
when we look at his situation we'll
we'll find that whatever he used to
worship other than God just like
everything else that we can worship
other than God mm-hmm it leaves us yeah
it leaves us and we're left with nothing
else but God in the end who we should
have worshipped mm-hmm and so when we
look at Yusef Addison I'm Joseph yeah
when he went into prison the story
that's given to us is about two people
now who are people of the prison and
with this story they asked them they
asked him about some of the dreams that
they had and before he tells them the
interpretation of dreams because he was
very skilled in interpreting the dreams
the first thing he tells them instead of
what he had what did he tell them he
tells him what what he has
he says in Lee toric to me let her call
me let me know Nabil and you were whom
will I feel at home Catherine I left to
people who don't believe in Allah they
don't believe in God and they just
believe in the next life he's talking
about what he has what about to me let's
add ibrahim oh it's married well it's my
you know what it's half my Canon and I'm
gonna be like you mean shake right and I
followed the way of my forefathers
Ibrahim and Ismail Abraham and Ishmael
and Isaac pure amount of theism once
again and we did not associate any
partners with God right so he instead of
him talking about because the first
thing you do when you go on to jail is
you talk about some of it to some of the
guys you talk about your lifestyle you
talk about what you used to have you
talk about the things that either you
loved or you hated right and here he is
talking about both talking about people
who didn't worship Allah and he talked
about the people who worshipped the one
and only deserving of worship God
himself when I take a break hold off
right there and we right back with more
here on the Deen show and it's simple to
understand I wouldn't know what the sky
looked like what the trees look like I
would have never seen the faces of my
beautiful children if I didn't have the
ability to see how blessed we are by
Allah and obedience is born out of
gratitude
so thank him call upon him establish a
relationship with him forget about the
past take it out of being a ritual and
make it a spiritual experience Islam is
not something dubious unclear hazy it's
really straightforward he said it
changed his life he said he saw every
single episode that you had ever
recorded
back here on a Dean show with brother
harun and humble lot you're very young I
mean you you you it would be something
that nowadays you know for someone to
quote-unquote be religious to be talking
about the Creator it's something that
people think like maybe I'll get to do
when I'm like 50 60 but how did you come
to this point in your life where you've
actually dedicated your life to a better
cause I mean all praises this whole lot
so hinata the whenever I when I was a
young a kid you know I thought my
parents really instilled they tried to
instill the devotion of worshiping Allah
worshiping God you know and educating me
on the importance of doing it and you
know Eman Buhari who is the narrator of
the OD or the the writer of the most
authentic narrations of the Prophet he
has a special chapter in his book called
and it's the book of knowledge and it
says the first sub chapter of the book
of knowledge is the it says the chapter
of knowledge before you speak and act
right and so that shows the importance
of knowing compared to not knowing and
also when we look at the the formulation
of the pillars of Islam and the pillars
of Eman right the pillars of Islam is of
course to worship no one other than God
to pray to fast to pay as a cat or your
annual charity that's obligatory when to
make your pilgrimage right and then the
second part is Eman right which is faith
and you can't have faith unless you know
you can have Islam with knowing just a
little bit but but the more you know the
more you love and if we look at the
bringing up of someone for example
Hernandez who we were talking about
earlier we
look at what he was taught as a child
right who were his parents and we're not
gonna say he had bad parents or anything
like that but what was your son doing
did you know you know there's a lot of
things even as a lot of the Muslim
families we don't devote a lot of time
towards educating our kids the
importance of the religion of Allah
rather we would force them to do this
enforce them to do that and they grow up
to become teenagers and they start to
question and they don't know why they're
praying they don't know why they're
giving charity they don't know why their
code the ladies don't know why they're
covering up they don't know why they
need to be Muslim it was because their
parents made them do this and made them
do that without properly educated can
someone use that as an excuse if they
had parents who are on drugs they came
from a very corrupt background can they
use that as an excuse and say look you
know that's I'm a product of my
environment and to continue on just
following their desires I mean what
would you say to someone like Aaron
Hernandez who says you don't you haven't
walked in my shoes you don't understand
what I've been through and just like you
know someone like Hernandez you know I
haven't walked in his shoes at all but
at the same time he hasn't walked in
mine nor as he walked in yours right and
so God says in the Quran what I thought
it was a rotten ways that Allah no one
is held accountable for what someone
else is doing so just because your
parents were going through what they
were going through it doesn't mean that
you're held accountable for what they
did
nor will they be had nor will they be
held accountable for what you do so you
can't blame what you're doing on your
parents once you know better you need to
change because there's people in two
predicaments who have been in the same
ghetto but one went to prison and one
ended up in the White House for instance
yeah I mean no I mean or somewhere went
today I mean to people I'm saying they
can end up in the White House and it's
going to end up in the penitentiary yeah
so but they came from the same hood yes
or the same environment is that right
yes and like God says in the Quran in
Allah neither you know might be home
they rule maybe I'm for saying God
doesn't change what's within of people
until they change all to the
what's within themselves yeah so if you
want better for yourself if you want to
move forward in your life
then what you need to do is change how
do you get someone to really contemplate
more on this okay you're because we're
talking about a subject now if we're
talking about baseball football
entertainment and you really people get
plugged in but now when you start
talking about this very important topic
purpose of life and why we've been
created you know where we're going when
we die of judge the day of judgment and
any time while God worshipping the
crater not his Christian you know a lot
of people they're just they many people
fall asleep to this because when they
look in there you know it doesn't fit
with their DVD collection or service
alone and Jack lonely or their CD Lady
gaga for dissent oh my god I don't have
him anywhere here so we stopped at my
prophets he started talking about a lot
of this is foreign to people why is it
so important to talk about this reflect
about it why is it such an important
topic to to go away from that direction
to this direction
what would you say to someone like Aaron
Hernandez if you had his word on why is
it so important because we need role
models we need good role models people
who will you open up their closet all
you see is clean clothes mm-hmm right
and we don't need the role models who
you start to open up closet their closet
and you know there's a little vomit
there there's a little the dead person
in the corner over there there's a
something that you know you didn't want
to see over there and you know it's just
a whole bunch of disgusting stuff in
this closet right we need good role
models and there are no better role
models in the profits no better role
models in the profits so you know
Hernandez for example Aaron Hernandez he
was a role model for the for the NFL he
was a role model for the people who play
football in terms of playing football
but if you came to look at his character
you probably wouldn't want to hang out
with the guy right I'm not saying he was
a bad guy maybe it was a nice day right
maybe you have friends that you didn't
want to hang out with right especially
if you were trying to be clean let's say
you were an alcoholic even want to be
around the guy let's say you were
addicted to drugs trying to recover you
didn't want to be
I'm the guy you didn't want to be around
him you don't want to be a lot of his
friends or nothing but you could always
always look towards the profits and the
people who were clean righteous purely a
monotheistic and always say that's
someone who I'd like to be in some way
shape or form
is it true because naturally if you keep
watching a particular movie star a
particular NFL player you're going to
start growing that attraction towards
them yeah you're not even physically but
I'm talking about just emotionally your
heart will get attached yeah and then
you're gonna want to mimic them isn't
that right and we just start mimicking
him yeah and we've seen people like for
example who died oh who cried when
Michael Jackson died when we Houston
died we we've seen people who who cried
when a lot of the James Brown James
Brown died you know people cried because
they they love these characters they and
it wasn't a real person that they loved
and that's the main thing it wasn't a
real person that they loved they loved
the character that the person
represented they loved the voice they
loved the musical artistry they loved
that acting capabilities but they didn't
fall in love with the person themselves
and for example if you were to look I
remember if I recall correctly Whitney
Houston had had a show with Bobby Brown
right and they were constantly fighting
and arguing yelling and screaming at
each other you know what kind of
lifestyle was that is that the kind of
lifestyle you want right is that what
you want your house to be like these are
all good questions that you need that
each and every one of us needs that when
we look at these role models we want to
look at their character first and their
ability second instead of looking at
their abilities first and their
characters tell their characteristics
second this way when we grow up as
young kids and you know have wise rawan
or husbands of our own kids of our own
houses of our own businesses of our own
jobs of our own we can start emulating
the proper character of the righteous
right and start and use people who have
good capabilities to learn what benefits
us from their capabilities and ignore
the character mm-hm make sense makes
sense so that's very important and would
you say that you know people they should
really reflect upon what happens when
that moment of deaf comes and is that
like the the end of it that's when you
have that that last I mean that's it you
can't your ability to make choice now is
over as there's area so now is the time
to get it right death is inevitable no
one's gonna say that I mean if anybody
says they're gonna live forever they're
either lying or crazy yeah right
so what's gonna happen after you die if
you've gone to anywhere else and you
haven't received the proper answers the
book of God the Quran has those answers
for you has all the answers all of them
let it make sense let's talk a little
bit more about that when we come back
here in the Dean show we'll be right
back bismillah alhamdulillah Salaam
alaikum peace be with you
this new land hamdulillah Salaam alaikum
peace be unto you Allah alhamdulillah
Salaam alaikum
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be unto you welcome to the Deen
show bismillah alhamdulillah Salam
alaikum peace be with few greetings of
peace to everybody all around the globe
that's tuning in to the D shop back here
on Adi show Aaron Hernandez topic of
this show NFL superstar was about to
make 40 million dollars yeah I mean the
majority of people don't won't see this
in ten lifetimes yeah so he's in a jail
cell now so the question is do we want
to follow people such as himself you
know actors actresses or put on a great
show for us but you talked about better
people to follow the messengers that the
crater sent to guide humanity what I
mean what was
the message that they came with they
came with you know every prophet and is
described in the Quran and subscribed in
the the Torah
it's just described in the Bible right
every messenger came with the same
message to worship the one and only
creator nothing else and to obey the
commandments that The Messenger has come
with from the crater from the Creator
from the maker mankind
yeah what does that mean when you say
worship people think okay you know I
gotta give up my job go in the room you
know and and just lock myself up and
what are you talking about when you say
worship bring it home with that you see
God says the Quran well Michael oxygen
no wood inside lady I belong I have only
created man and jinn to worship me
meaning worshiping God right and what is
worshiping God entail the basics of
course you know to make your five
prayers a day or to supplicate him to
worship God and the one and only God but
let's see hmm you worship God right you
need to eat right how many of us can
live without eating right in order to
worship God we need to maintain this
beautiful body that God has given us
right so you need to take care of it you
need to maintain it what do you need to
do that you need a job right so that
means there's a basic jurisprudence rule
right among the the people of
jurisprudence right Maya and Tim McGraw
ji Hui Levesque for watch if anything
that is that you need in order to
accomplish what is necessary meaning
like prayer then that is also necessary
right so anything that you need in order
to accomplish what is mandatory is also
mandatory so therefore you're going to
work where work in order to be able to
take care of your body in order to be
able to take care of your family in
order to be able to eat in order to be
able to drink in order to be able to
think in order to be able to call
mankind all of this working becomes a
form of worship right you being at you
going to
becoming educated this can be a form of
worship right you smile into your
neighbors having good relationships with
your neighbors having being good to your
children being good to your of family
members all of this becomes a form of
worship because you cannot possibly have
an easy time worshiping God when you
have problems everywhere right so
therefore you keeping good relationships
with your family not causing problems
and doing things to prevent problems
becomes a form of worship so in a
nutshell anything that we do that is
good that coincides with the
commandments of God is a form of worship
if we have the proper intentions for
proper intentions and doing it for the
pleasure of the Creator everything that
he loves yes can we connect be
constituted as form of servitude worship
yes
so you mentioned being good to your
neighbor rather rather he be a not yet
Muslim or Muslims that's true yeah okay
saving saving a human being let's say
you know from from you know destroying
his self helping someone get off drugs
or helping someone to become a better
human being as an act of worship being
kind to your parents definitely what
else can we lose a long side with the
five pillars of praying five times a day
fasting all these things that help us to
be Morgan conscious what else on the
list goes on being good it could be a
good to your community being good to
your neighbor
how about avoiding bad things waiting
problems you can connect like say
avoiding adultery gambling where you
might have the the tendency that you
want to do it but you avoid it you did
it for the crater is that active worship
all of that's the form of worship yeah
all of that's the form worship as a
matter of fact there's a there's a
beautiful story I don't think we have
enough time to go through it but this
one guy was was on the verge of
committing fornication and he withdrew
and God rewarded him tremendously
because he withdrew and he didn't commit
go through with the fornication for the
sake of God
so what advice would you have for
someone like Aaron Hernandez who's
sitting in jail so right now and if this
gets to him or you know maybe he's able
to get some first-class treatment he's
watching the Dean show yeah or one of
his friends watch awaken give him a
message what would you tell him look for
a piece look for peace in the Creator
just like Joseph even though he was in
prison he told people what he had he
told people what God has given him and
that was the piece in worshiping the one
and only creator rather than looking for
the things that won't last you buy a car
today
make sure it'll be old you get a pretty
girl today three years she'll be old
right is that how long it takes for a
lot a lot a lot slower than that right
everybody gets everything just fades out
yeah if it's tiring you get bored with
it yeah but she's still pretty or he's
though you know but you get his tired
yeah yeah but we worship allah subhana
wa ta'ala the crater yeah right he's
forever mm-hmm and he'll be there
forever
yeah he'll always be there and just like
Joseph said at the end of that story
right in the human year today well Smith
but in a lot like those indeed those who
are god-fearing and they persevere and
their patience and God will never ever
forsake the rewards of those who strive
towards his profession strive towards
goodness yes sorry towards the crater
before we go good company please in one
minute because it was also said that he
went from his bad company of friends he
went up scale up town met some new bad
friends and brought his old bad friends
to meet his new bad friends and you see
what happens when you have bad friends
yeah you're doing bad drugs yeah and
going to bad parties and you just live
in a bad life and you see what ends up
at the end yeah so for people now who
aren't in jail and they really you know
most people want to change but they need
a little extra motivation good company's
very important too isn't it extremely
and the Provost autumn said a lot while
I didn't holiday the every human being
their lifestyle is the same as their
friends all right so if you want to
change the first thing you have to do is
try to change your friends if you and
one other thing one of the amazing
things is when you start to change
right the thing the friends that you had
before the bad friends they begin to
kind of fade away if you change for the
worse those good friends that you had
will start to fade away and you'll start
to get you know those whatever group of
friends look like the old saying you
know a bird of a flower the birds of a
feather flock together yeah right and
it's a very true statement
it's a very true statement and there was
a story of a man for example who killed
99 people and when he killed 99 people
he went to a monk and he told the monk
you know is there any possibility that I
go to heaven and the monk said no you're
going to hell and so he killed him - all
right and this was before the time of
the Prophet Muhammad SAW said and so he
then goes to another guy and he says is
there any possibility that I go to
heaven
I killed a hundred people yeah I said
yeah but you got to leave this place
this place is not a good place for you
mm-hmm so he just packs up and leave you
didn't even pack up just walked and on
his way out he on his way to the next
place where the guy advised him to go to
he died right but he left his friends
behind him leaving shows that he was
trying to leave it all behind he was a
state of repentance also that was being
in a state of repentance yeah so that he
can change the guy was telling him the
truth he couldn't have changed with that
group of company that he had before and
even if he stayed there and tried to get
rid of that group of company guess what
they're still there yeah they're still
tugging on you they're still pulling
right so if you need if you want to
change eventually the long term is to
make a long story short this guy
until he went to heaven because he was
trying to change and he left that that
place
not everybody can leave the place they
are that they're in but the moment that
you find that opportunity if you're
trying to change the moment that you
find that gap in in that that hole in
that the light in that tunnel
the moment that there's this little hair
length of an opportunity you need to get
out yes this company is very important
mm-hmm lay down with dogs you're gonna
get fleas
like you said birds of a feather flock
they gather together she got to be
around good company thank you very much
logical epic nice being on here thank
you very much thank you so long that's
all I got and there you have it on the
Dean show giving you some great advice
like us on facebook follow us on twitter
and hashtag price for those of you you
know we're getting hip on all these
social media tools using it as a forum
to help deliver the message of peace
purpose this last mission to the will of
the creator and one of those that we
have like we said look we we we want to
use the Twitter now and have you also
for those people who have it hashtag
priceless blessings let's talk priceless
blessings and what mention knows right
now because if we one of those right now
is is is and there's so many I mean if
you were trying to enumerate all the
blessings of the crater's given you you
couldn't do it so one of those is great
health you know when we have good health
that the Creator has given us and Aaron
Hernandez was blessed with that good
health I mean how many people how many
athletes are out there like him who were
able to because of his gift of
athleticism he was able to almost
achieve a great reward a forty million
dollars Megan was good he could he could
have done with that now he's sitting in
to jail so so maybe if we reflect more
about the blessings that the Creator has
given us we ponder morph of these many
gifts that the maker of mankind has
given us it helped us to leave it be a
little more thankful because when
someone gives you a dollar bill you say
thank you hundred dollars buys you a
meal you say thank you but the countless
gifts that the Creator has given us I
mean they're priceless so let's talk
about the priceless blessings hashtag
I'm sorry hashed
at the Twitter go-to at the Dean show
hashtag priceless what do we say
priceless blessings let's say priceless
blessings is that what it is priceless
blessings and let's just see how many
you can come up with just start
listening I'll tell you a few your eyes
magic if you can see the feeling of
touch you know so many we could just
make a pro so many programs of this so
go to the D show.com from there go to
our Twitter page
hashtag priceless blessings at the Dean
show and let's see how many we could
stimulate some some some of your your
imagination and you know really start to
think of all these great blessings to
help us motivate us to be more thankful
to the one who created us so we can be
on a path of goodness and we can achieve
that greatest prize paradise at the end
on the day of judgment when the crater
brings us to account for everything
we've done in this life because there's
a test and we want to pass the test and
avoid the Hellfire we'll see you next
time here on a Deen show until then
peace be with you